no
oh hey
oh my god you're friends you're the most
precious thing i've ever seen in my
entire oh my god there's a two
you have a friend hi
oh
my god
are you being so good
are you you being so good this is the
best thing ever hi it's imu liu and i'm
here with buzzfeed to answer your
questions while playing with puppies
which is crazy how is that even a thing
that you do anyway bring them
oh my god i can hear them i'm so excited
i'm i'm happy to answer your question in
just one second oh we're just going to
okay
okay so there's the one scene this one's
name is minnie the scene oh hello on the
airplane
we were in the airplane and then i was
trying to explain to her how to
pronounce my name it was that one
and
noir is very funny we had lots of long
takes where we were we were improvising
and and it was really great and she's a
comedic genius and what's your name
where do these puppies come i have so
many questions
my favorite memory of working with
michelle is that she loves to dance in
between oh my god she loves to like
dance in between takes she's
honestly such a such a goofball in real
life i feel like she plays a lot of
these really like kind of
frigid intimidating characters and oh
hello oh hello just how like fun she is
and goofy and warm so i think that's
that's definitely my favorite part of
working with her and and also how much
she loves like getting people together
for group dinners
because i know that's something that i
love doing too
i would love to interact with korg from
thor ragnarok or like
you know one of the ones that don't get
a lot of love oh my god oh my god a
character that doesn't have their own
their own movie maybe like adopting it'd
be like adopting a marvel character much
like all of these dogs are available for
adoption are they not are they not can
you come home with me
oh my god oh that's a good question
that's a good question you know i was
pretty star struck by steph curry i'm
not gonna lie i did manage to muster up
the courage to say hi i was really star
struck meeting these guys i definitely
didn't have that reaction is that a
shoelace is that a shoelace
it was a crazy crazy whirlwind i feel
like
oh my god i feel like i just didn't get
any sleep but in the best possible way
it was just it was
so incredibly overwhelming but also
really educational
everyone on that cast is so like so
incredibly funny it was like a master
class it was a master class in comedy it
was a master class in comedy puppy
i forgot the question i feel like it was
that's my shoelace
that's my shoe hey you the first
um movie or tv character that i saw
probably like the yellow ranger and the
original power rangers which you know
out out that's my shin and my shoelace
you know it wasn't it wasn't subtle it
was like the early 90s version of um
diversity it was like the yellow ranger
was asian it was pretty cool i remember
how that made me feel it kind of
just sent a jolt of electricity through
me seeing that for the first time and um
it kind of means the word
that's not a snack that's my shoe you're
silly
you're silly it's a tremendous honor
just because we didn't have
a lot of that representation when i was
when i was younger so to see kids
dressing up as chunky for halloween
being fans and and
seeing themselves reflected in in in
that way i think is extremely meaningful
and everyone should have a dog
you're silly
you're silly i did every stunt that i
could have i i fought for a lot i think
a lot of producers on our movie were
very protective of me which you know i
really appreciated i really wanted to
put my best foot forward i wanted to
take ownership over the the the
physicality uh and the movement of the
character and so
i fought to do as much as i could i
would say at the end probably like 70 75
of the stars i was kind of like an
on-again off against stuntman working in
toronto before then
um in addition to acting and it was kind
of like a substitute statement that's my
shoe
you're so silly that's my [ __ ] look at
all these toys isn't it funny that dogs
always pick the one thing that's like
not a toy
and then just fixate on that those are
shoes you silly gooses silly goose
i got to take his jordans oh god oh ow
oh oh my god oh those are very teethy
there's a lot of teeth in that kiss took
some shirts i didn't take the costume
the costume itself is it comes in like
three pieces it's actually really really
difficult to put on and impossible to do
by yourself so it wouldn't have done me
any good to take it home but at some
point i'll have the version that's
easier to put on whoa
whoa whoa guys
guys play nice
what that's like asking me which one of
these beautiful little creatures i like
the most you can't do that you love them
all equally they're all equally strong
isn't that right oh that's still my
shoelace though we cannot give these
back okay let me just tie these up real
quick my answer is no answer i don't
think any
oh oh hello i can't choose i think
i think all of them are equally powerful
i will say wanda i think is the only one
that can like mess with reality maybe
she might have a slight just because of
that what do you think what do you think
baby i am so scratched up all over but
it's okay
love island i'm kidding i'm kidding
that's not true the bachelor also
kidding maybe succession maybe stranger
things
thor ragnarok my favorite marvel
cinematic universe movie is the four
wagons
i would love to play spider-man i used
to play spider-man at kids birthday
parties and nobody ever believed that i
was spider-man so i feel
like that'd be a good one
definitely oh
definitely an ice cap or a double double
oh my god oh my god so many ryan
reynolds hugh jackman
meryl streep
denzel washington michael b jordan
stephen ewan right
aren't those good actors steve and i
choose good actors
my favorite episode of kim's
conveniences is when i visit up in the
hospital it's the first time that we've
seen each other in such a long time and
we have these like really awesome moment
remember shooting the scene with
paul sun hyung lee who plays uppa
and um it was just so emotional it's
such an emotional moment for the both of
us wasn't it a fun show
i really love this place fishman lobster
clubhouse it's about 30 minutes out of
the city oh my god i think she's
following us
oh no you're stealing
what's going on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa play time's getting a
little rough over here guys you get
these massive towers of lobster drizzled
in like black bean sauce or like
stir-fried with ginger scallion really
oh in my opinion the best way to have
lobster
and um and there's no restaurant that
does it quite like fish
guys
that's a nibble
oh that's a hand that's a hand my love
whoa man uh one true loves is is a is an
amazing novel written by the incredible
taylor jenkins read and i was lucky
enough to play the character of sam was
just shooting it actually we just
wrapped about a week ago in wilmington
north carolina it was just such an
incredible experience i really got to
delve into the character of sam and what
i really love about him is is his
kindness there's a there's a kindness
and a generosity to him
that i don't think you see very often in
in romantic leads in movies i think a
lot of times
you know the male lead is like this
really aggressive guy or he'll he'll
make this like grand gesture and and the
you know the women are always like oh my
god you know but i think what sam does
that nobody else
that is really special about him is that
he listens i'm really excited for people
to watch it
i remember the the one thing i did was i
slid over the top of the bus i swung
around the side and i i smashed into the
door but we got that in like a few takes
i would say like the hardest thing for
me to do i was trying to manipulate the
rings and the rings weren't actually
there so i had to like try to imagine
trying to focus on
points in space that like were just not
there so they're like okay the rings are
in front of you now they're moving
around and it's just like weird because
your eyes can't focus on something
that's not tactile but somehow somehow
we found a way in the end we found a way
didn't we guys
my go-to karaoke song is probably
aladdin it's probably oh you want me to
what do you want me to sing it you want
me to sing it to you i can show you the
world oh
shining shimmering splendid
tell me princess that when did you
you're biting my face off ouch we were
asked to give a list of our of our
go-to's and and not all of them made it
but but thankfully that one did
my parents make the best dumplings in
the world period ow no argument it just
it's just true i've had a lot of
dumplings from a lot of different places
and my parents are the best they have
the best one
my favorite fan story is uh i was
shooting a movie in the dominican
republic i met one of the dog extras
that were on set and then i fell in love
and then i took her home with me i took
her home like someone's gonna take you
home it's true
probably superman i just love the idea
that he was kind of like an immigrant in
a way
like even though he was he was living
among among humans like he wasn't really
from there and he was constantly having
to
you know in some ways hide who he really
was i just i think i related to that oh
my god this has been absolute torture
no it hasn't this is the best you can
get shanxi in the legend of the ten
rings on uh november 30th out on blu-ray
all of these animals are adoptable
through north shore animal league
america you can take these beautiful
beautiful puppies home what's that
what's that you think somebody watching
right now is gonna adopt you
i think you're right i think you're
right baby can i stay can you all come
home with me you wanna meet chopa
[Music]
you